bon cher ami gilles ce soir je vais
réaliser le fantasme de milliers de
téléspectateurs et notamment de joey
starr et de michel cymes je vais vous
lire gautier devait voter
est-ce que vous acceptez ce challenge
pour vous oui à d'être sûr pour vous
supra tout rejoignez-moi sur la scène
julien tomas
un poil de graisse c'est parfait et
magnifique de papillons merci voilà avec
les compliments de la maison un peu
émules pourquoi c'est pas vous allez me
matas chéri côté absolument aux douces
un peu tendu au pays oui j'ai jamais été
du côté de ma vie donc inquiéter pas ici
tout est bienveillance
on va essayer d'apporter un peu de masse
jusqu'à avoir confiance en vous êtes
serein sûr n'oubliez pas que c'est vous
qui faites le tour c'est moi qui fais le
tour et 8 en or
j'avais oublié alors ici se trouve une
corde extrêmement solide et je vais vous
attacher la main de cette manière
regarde ma part je suis moche et 1,7 go
c'est comme barack obama allait génisson
away avec les mains droites sont
dégainés on est d'accord
bon vous placez de cette manière et je
vais vous attacher la deuxième mandat
bien gilles où tout va bien valent bien
un groupement tactique break qu'elle a
fermé un peu j'avais un c est un travail
de dur labeur et je fais trois ne rien
pour vous gilles verdez à aston villa
s'est longuement attaché au leader est
très facile à présent on va passer à la
vitesse supérieure supérieur ici voile
et je récupère la coop et je vous la
place où tout anormal et rayonnait le
tweet est ce qu'on fait un remake us à
construire et franchement ce serait pas
mal à travers de ça fait quand même une
petite manon la première ça fait un peu
où là je veux la phase un logiciel à
bout ce n'est d'aller m'étrangler la non
vous inquiétez pas et vomir non ménagers
j'avais déjà vomi avec musulin
commençait alors le peuple est morte et
encore ce soir non oui comment de cette
manière ce tour et tout public je tiens
le prêcheur nar de la retirer très
content et c'est une femme et je place
évidemment la corde
de la meilleure façon je suis tout
excité actif le pervers pépère pervers
mais rien que ça hop ou blessé face à
moi dire un poulet rôti de we are il est
pas encore grillé
alors là je réalise le fantasme de
tellement de france à wes imaginé par on
imaginera pas tous à la place à la la la
vous êtes plutôt on voudrait faire ça et
kelly plus tôt ah oui je lui ai proposé
la volière
qu'est ce qui se passe maintenant vous
avez vous tourné alors là j'arrive sur
votre arrière ne voyait rien de vaut
serré plus du rôle axial faire les
gentils choix faut serrer plus frais
vallon j'habite au hockey tournez vous
vers moi bon il rien de tendancieux a
besoin est très bizarre là mais en est
son jouet web télé bien les jambes sert
les jambes
voilà reste et gtalk t il pour un
dépannage se fit parvenir
bon c'est vrai aussi que c'est pas grave
parce que vous êtes suffisamment armé ah
oui c'est sûr mais là dessus très bien
bon on nous avons un gilles verdez royal
et boîte pour votre niveau du ventre et
vous étouffez vraiment alors à présent
je vais avoir besoin de quelqu'un dans
le public quelqu'un qui porte une veste
pas papa attendait lever la main qui
accueille veste de costard comme moi b à
messieurs bonjour à votre prénom
mehdi un mec je pouvais pour mehdi
[Applaudissements]
bahmani wala dit prenez le nippo si vous
avez des goûts retrouviez et grands en
fait parce qu autant que vous elle selon
vous aviez dit que en venant sur ce
plateau assister tranquillement à une
émission de télévision ou pourriez
peut-être participé à un tour est ce que
vous êtes prêts à remplir le challenge
de gilles verdez ça me pose aucun souci
aucun souci pour ça aussi
qu'est ce qu'on va faire vous allez
rentrer tous les deux dans la capitale
et dans laquelle alors c'est un tour
absolument tout public pour entrer à
l'intérieur vous placez intérieur a
laissé vous aussi les dames amélie 2002
excusez moi mais vrai oui tout cas le
faire voilà c'est mon métier lehbila je
vais vous 38 ans et quel est votre
métier comptable comptable d'accord vous
savez compter les souples dans une
banque
entre autres si vous êtes venus ici
c'est parce que vous êtes fan de magie
oui c'est ça d'accord à votre plus grand
magicien à part moi évidemment à part
vous
mon père était un grand magicien oui
commission saville man ou non mais en
fait ça à chaque noël en fait ils oublié
ça oui c'est très bien spécialité comme
toi allez on se remet déjà dcns qui se
passe
j'ai le vernet one est attaché au niveau
regarder passer à travers ici tournez
vous vous êtes toujours attaché oui que
l'on voit avant après les incroyables à
genève est déjà incroyable comment as-tu
fallait deviner
j'en ai aucune idée en fait j'étais en
train de parler avec vous je me suis
rien y avait un partenaire
extraordinaire
ah oui des flux magique à des joutes
leader jusqu'à 6h en france avait tout
fait vraiment là voilà si vous verrez
voulait récupérer votre veste monsieur
avait s'il vous plaît oui très bien eux
c'est combien 50 balles 50 balles alors
écoutez vous libérer merci beaucoup aidé
[Applaudissements]
et gilles gilles on vous laisse
multiplient
[Applaudissements]